[Music]
we gotta tune in to the next social
knockout social knockout three three
yeah bro
yeah supposedly austin mcbroom is gonna
fight deji
really i don't know
i was watching some uh some tommy fury
highlights to look at his fight style
it's gonna be interesting when is that
fight i don't know is that okay don't
tell me i don't care yeah i'm not gonna
care this time i'm not gonna buy i'm not
gonna watch it not even gonna
tune into any news about it i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm gonna watch it it's over no
don't watch it i'll watch a bootleg
stream live it's over
because who gives a [ __ ]
we have to stop caring it's going to be
a good fight no it's not it is it's
going to be ass no it's not it's going
to be a good fight it's going to suck
ass i'm telling you it's going to be a
good fight
i don't care i know
you hate to admit it this is like elon
having a good tweet jake's gonna have a
good fight
here's why though
tommy's style is very like
he is relentless it's surprising how
much he doesn't quit
super fast hands and like he's like in
there
and any time jake has buckled it's when
he gets pressured okay so it'll be
really interesting to see
if
all of jake's training goes out the
window before he maintains that
composure it's gonna be
that's really interesting it is
times won't give a [ __ ] tommy's got
knockout power
does he yeah [ __ ] i don't care yeah i
don't care he's got knockout power is he
oh it would be nice i don't care i don't
care i don't care i mean you know tommy
no it would be nice to see it would be
nice to see that though here's the thing
uh
uh tyron was able to wobble jake
yeah that's true and uh
so you know i mean anyone can get
wobbled in the ring that's not anything
special but what i'm saying is tyron who
doesn't have necessarily like uh a
boxing acumen was able to get close and
touch him up
and tommy's thing is he's got this
[ __ ] whipping uppercut that he just
throws like over and over
and uh
if that lands
i don't know bro
i don't know jake said uh pucker up
timmy it's time to kiss your last name
and your family's boxing legacy goodbye
december 18th not that that matters i'm
changing this wanker's name to tommy
fumbles and celebrating with tom brady
it's on sale november 10th
interesting
there's a lot riding on this tommy like
literally cannot lose to him
because otherwise his career is over
yeah it's like oh it's gonna be really
embarrassing and people are sort of you
know he he fought like this 5-7 dude
from bellator and he kind of struggled
to put him away and i think
the height difference was weird and i
mean even tommy admitted it was a [ __ ]
performance but
tommy's got great combos for
you know
relative to other people in boxing i
would
my understanding is he's not as far
along as he should be
but uh
yeah
i only dove deep on all this [ __ ] after
the ufc fight i just you know the
adrenaline was good those were good
fights it's one of those special cars
everyone got killed yep yep
really enjoyed that
and then i watched the
uh end of the canelo fight which was
also really exciting okay la plant yeah
yeah yeah that uppercut is mean bro
same one that put away uh the other dude
busted his orbital i think um
similar thing one dude i was sad for was
it was the dude shane burgos like in the
he's in the middle of the card that dude
is like a very
that's the type of fighter that uh
taylor holder thinks he is
yeah like a very clean technical
in the pocket can kind of roll with it
um he couldn't get started but like that
dude when when he's on
he's nice so i was i was sad to
everyone was tweeting that i looked like
the other guy billy q that's you not in
that shot but it was like his hair was
all puffed up
uh go back to the search i think there's
like a better you're like not in that
not in that one i definitely don't look
like him there
i think like he grew his hair out or
like he didn't put any product in for
the birthday
for sure
oh yeah 100 yeah that's me that captures
my body perfectly yep
yep that's you two always rocking those
aviators yeah
no i think it was when it was his hair
puffed up and he was getting punched in
the [ __ ] face that's when people were
like oh dude that looks like you yeah
yeah that definitely looks like you
do we have that garyvee tick tock by
chance oh yeah that'd be great or is it
definitely offline
yes run it
two
see some people see
network
i see two i see different things that
people see seriously so it's a real
insight yeah i think you're right
drock don't rip off
this guy i see i see a rat
i see a rat
isn't that incredible
they're on the streets of new york city
he's like pointing towards some like
marketing billboard of just words and
he's basically saying like i see
different words inside other words
because i'm different and then some guy
looks at another word he goes oh yeah
like i see joy in that word he said dude
don't [ __ ] rip off my thing bro
what else can we see here
hat
inside of manhattan yeah i see tan you
see dude inside of manhattan
yeah at least pick a different [ __ ]
word sorry dude i thought that was going
somewhere
i see tunity and opportunity i see [ __ ]
right then
oh dude
i saw a hilarious tick tock last night
it was like
look at some young girl being like if i
see one more sexy australian on tick
tock and then it like
cuts to this
big burly boy comes in he's like hey
kant
then he props his leg up and he falls
back
kid had to be like 350
oh hey [ __ ]
[Music]
isn't that funny how insulted he got
also also like him reassuring the camera
guy the camera guy clearly thought he
was joking like he's like i too look at
this i see different things and the guy
that's like come on no seriously that's
a real insight
i'm special no seriously no seriously i
look like billy q seriously i look like
billy q i look like him people were
definitely saying i look like a roided
ufc fighter people were definitely
saying that this real insight for sure
that's real insight no no seriously
seriously that's a serious thing people
are tweeting me like dude your abs are
just like this yeah yeah
seriously
seriously
seriously seriously it's real insight
yeah
like i thought he was going somewhere
with that
i was gonna be like if you'll see
network i see two because there's two
people you know like i thought that's
also such a good part is that there was
no follow-up what's good about seeing
two in networks why would that be a
benefit to you oh so you're like you
can't read like that's what's not yes
you're dyslexic yeah
uh gary what does this say two men hat
tan
no it's network in manhattan oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] i see i saw a two-in-man hat
so you see network i see two
as in two boobs
okay okay
this [ __ ]
joy if tan
tunity necked
two right here dude you're insane
[Laughter]
seriously come on we gotta seriously
stop don't don't jack my thing dude we
gotta go we gotta get my next batch of
kratom let's go
see you see your family
i see them getting shot
[Laughter]
and that's the difference between you
and me you see nice
i see into the trash compactor
fingers first
[Laughter]
you see a blender
you think smoothie
i think
uh squid going in there tentacles first
you see stairs
i see a vacation for your grandma
someone messaged me recently saying like
why are your bits lately so violent
because it's funny
yeah
yeah it is funny
you see violence
yeah we see humor
he's different you see violent
we see lent
no end yeah entertainment
no it has to make no sense yeah
we see lent we see
viol
what seriously that's real insight
[Music]
what did he just say
what did he say